non
[Musique]
oh
doctor strange sortie en 2016 et
découvert que récemment pour ma part il
est possiblement moins héros préférés du
mc hue ancien chirurgien de génie devenu
un sorcier très prometteur et l'étain
personnage que j'aime beaucoup et qui
m'intrigue réellement et pour cela
j'aimerais donc vous proposer une vidéo
sur ce dernier mettant millau marvel
récemment et cherchant de nouveaux
sujets pour mes vidéos n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
bref voici donc les trois théories que
je vous propose
pour cette première théorie si vous ne
vous rappelez pas de la fin du film de
doctor strange ce dernier face à kei si
luce puis quitte le combat pour
finalement atteindre dormammu dans la
dimension noir stéphane strange créera
une boucle temporelle face à l'être
surpuissant lui permettant de bloquer et
d'enfermer dormammu dans une sorte de
prison temporel cependant strange ne
possède pas le pouvoir de le vaincre
et comme précisé par dormammu tugnutt
bienvenus ce à quoi strange répondra
qu'il peut perdre encore et encore et
encore éternellement
et c'est là que la théorie devient
intéressante personne ne sait combien de
temps à peu près strange a passé face à
dorment amour le film ne nous aide pas
davantage sur cette information mais il
est fortement possible voire
certainement que strange a passé
d'innombrables années face à l'être
surpuissant à mourir en boucle
certains parlent d'environ trois ans et
demi d'autres de plusieurs siècles et
d'autres parlent carrément de dix mille
en deux boucles temporelles ce qui est
je pense assez excessive tout de même
néanmoins ce qui est sûr c'est que dr
strange a passé des années façade
dormammu avant que ce dernier ne cède à
sa négociation est justement pendant ces
années strange n'a fait que de combattre
dormammu malgré qu'il se fasse écraser à
chaque fois qu'il peut perdre encore et
encore et encore et encore mais j'ai
envie de vous dire
pour gagner il faut savoir perdre et
perdre fait partie de la réussite ces
années à mourir face à dormammu n'ont
été que bénéfique pour doctor strange
qui au final lui permis d'approfondir
ses pouvoirs en combattant sans relâche
pour l'éternité dorment à meaux et le
sorcier le plus puissant et tire son
pouvoir de plusieurs races interdit
mentionnait qui le vénère ainsi que de
la dimension noir ce dernier est éternel
il ne peut mourir à cause du temps la
preuve avec l'ancien qui survivaient
éternellement grâce à la dimension noir
aussi il est comparable tel un dieu donc
il était forcément obligé que strange
doivent recommencer la boucle durant des
années avant qu'il ne cède pour
continuer sur l'ancien il faut savoir
que ces dernières c'est laisser partir
car c'était son destin
d'après ce qu'elle nous dit mais
j'aurais plutôt une autre version sur
pourquoi s est laissé partir
elle voyait plusieurs futures sur elle
même sur le monde sur doctor strange est
cette dernière qui s'alimentait grâce à
la dimension noir décide soudainement de
se laisser partir avec l'excusé du
destin je pense qu'en fait cette
dernière a dû voir quelque chose dans
strange son futur et son combat face à
dormammu et que justement ce dernier
amplifierait nettement ses pouvoirs
durant ces années de boucles temporelles
jusqu'à développer un grand pouvoir et
donc devenir un jour ou l'autre le
sorcier suprême car oui tout est fait
pour que strange soit le nouveau sorcier
suprême plusieurs fans pense qu'il l'est
déjà d'ailleurs
de plus cela reste fictif mais dans les
comics l'ancien savait déjà que strange
et et son successeur alors qu'il n'était
encore qu'un enfant
son pouvoir se serait alors développé
durant un entraînement face à la mort
qui aurait duré pendant de nombreuses
années
face à un sorcier surpuissant et éternel
dorment amour n'hésitez pas à me dire ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires
quoi
comment ça vous trouvez que la théorie
nul réellement bon très bien voici donc
les trois théories que je vous propose
[Musique]
pour cette première théorie docteur
strange fut très apprécié et a rapporté
plus de 85 millions de dollars au box
office
donc vous pouvez être certain qu'un
docteur strange 2 fera son apparition
et justement il est prévu pour 2020
néanmoins que pourrait-il se passer dans
ce prochain opus
tout d'abord n'oublions pas la scène
post générique ou bordeaux tu penses
bornes en affirmant qu'il ya trop de
sorcier donc une mise en salle équilibre
naturel de la vie il est donc sûr et
certain que bordeaux sera le prochain
vilain de doctor strange 2 il
deviendrait donc normalement baron
bordeaux le rival de doctor strange
ensuite que savons-nous sur ce prochain
opus
le scénariste de doctor strange house
jones bates a laissé sous-entendre que
nous pourrions enfin rencontrer clés à
l'écran dans le prochain opus
c'est un personnage difficile à
interpréter parce que son oncle est une
sorte de dieu omnipotent et ténébreux et
elle est une sorte de fille qui étudie
la magie c'est une relation difficile à
sortir d'une bande dessinée et sur un
écran de cinéma
mais elle est un personnage vraiment
fascinant comme un fleuret un intérêt
amoureux un collègue du docteur strange
et elle porte toujours avec elle cette
largeur de mystère quant à savoir si
elle est humaine et comment humain ce
que cela signifie pour sa relation avec
m nous pourrions donc trouver un moyen
de la présenter à l'histoire
léa et le grand amour de doctor strange
est la nièce de dormammu lui même
cependant son histoire est beaucoup trop
complexe pour que la bande dessinée soit
retranscrite
donc attendez-vous à de nombreux
changements dans les films
d'ailleurs sa complexité donna naissance
au personnage de christine palmer qui
est l'amour du dr strange film pour
simplifier l'histoire mais cycléa est
attendu pour la suite de dr strange un
triangle amoureux pourraient se créer ou
du moins certains conflits
maintenant si on passe outre l'histoire
d'amour nous savons que dans l'histoire
de dr strange bordeaux rejoint dormammu
moment pour justement se venger de
doctor strange de lui avoir volé sa
destinée d'être l'héritier de l'ancien
cependant ce n'est pas le même type de
personnage que nous avons dans le film
dans les comics bordeaux n'hésite pas à
utiliser des pouvoirs temporel ou encore
la dimension noir alors que dans les
films il souhaite justement purifier le
monde d'un surplus de sorciers dont
docteur strange si nous cherchons dans
les ennemis de doctor strange nous
pouvons penser adac d'argent ce dernier
s'oppose justement la magie et est un
religieux qui pense que son devoir est
d'éradiquer le mysticisme
personnellement cela me fait énormément
penser aux convictions de bordeaux dans
les films qui semble être loin d'être le
même que dans les comics ce dernier
pourrait peut-être s'allier à die
d'argent qui semble posséder à peu près
les mêmes convictions ou bien s'allier à
dormammu pour contrer justement strange
et cléa il est quasiment sûr cycle et a
fait son apparition que deux ennemis
alliés seront face à nos deux héros mais
je suis certain que bordeaux ne sera pas
le même que dans les comics et
m'intrigue réellement sur son avenir
dans les films bon est ce que cette
théorie vous a plu quoi comment ça
toujours pas voici donc les trois
théories que je vous propose
et
pour cette première théorie j'aimerais
commencer fort avec un petit débat
philosophique car dr strange fera partie
des infinity ward et donc sera dans les
prochains marvel cependant contrairement
aux autres dr strange amène la magie
dans le mc eu mais de la réelle magie
aucune explication scientifique n'existe
pour identifier les pouvoirs de l'ex
chirurgien prenons l'exemple de tony
stark iron man menacé pouvoir que grâce
à une armure donc lié à la technologie
soi explicable scientifiquement
pareil pour banner qui se transforme en
hulk car il a été exposé aux rayons
gamma lors d'une explosion atomique
captain america un sérum du super-soldat
le triple est plus un traitement vita
rayons ainsi que d'un entraînement
physique intensif d'orb à ces indus à la
base et n'est pas un terrien bref mais
qu'en est-il de doctor strange
il s'est juste entraîné et a suivi un
cours particulier pour maîtriser et de
véritables pouvoirs
pas d'accident pas de sérum pas de
rayons gamma rien et c'est là le gros
mystère de la chose pour moi car
techniquement docteur strange et over
tchité pour les futurs films de marvel
du moins pour les terriens il est censé
dépasser n'importe quel héros comment
marvel va t'il équilibrer la chose car
cela voudrait aussi dire que des ennemis
comme cas ici lieu sous certainement
bordeaux ou dormammu feront leur retour
et eux savent utiliser la magie donc que
ce soit captain america iron man hulk
ils n'ont pas la moindre chance
contrairement à strange qui a très bien
su le montrer
il peut remonter le temps rien que ça
mais bon ça devrait être chamboulé dans
le prochain film avengers luc selliez
une pierre d'infinité mais surtout il
pourra certainement voyager entre les
dimensions
souvenez vous comment ils humilient
lockheed en tort rania rock par exemple
et si c'est le cas que se passera-t-il
ensuite est-ce que les avengers
traverseront les dimensions est ce que
doctor strange rencontrera un autre
captain america d'une autre dimension
qui sera maléfique par exemple ou
chauffeurs de taxi ou n'en sais rien du
tout ça se trouve il tombera peut-être
sur riquet morty n'en trêve de
plaisanterie
derrickson l'un des réalisateurs du film
the doctor strange ajustements mentionné
ce point comme quoi le mystère était
fait exprès que la magie est magique
on ne peut pas la définir mais si ce
trench doit paraître dans les prochains
marvel que cela signifierait-il ça se
trouve nous aurons le droit 1 à 20
heures sous les protagonistes
traverseront les dimensions pour sauver
une réalité liée à la terre on n'en sait
rien du tout enfin bref c'est compliqué
tout ça mais je vous conseille d'y
réfléchir grandement en tout cas merci à
ceux qui laisseront un pouce bleus et
qui partageront la vidéo j'espère que ma
théorie vous aura plu tiens d'ailleurs
argot ça tombe bien que tu parles d
infinity ward car on doit justement
terminé à la vidéo touche taille rouge
teint c'est censé être un secret encore
pour le moment
bon bah
attendez je vais remonter le temps
histoire de sauver les meubles
encore une fois et merde
[Musique]